this week we've got dead milk stumbled
weddings and angry idiot
I want stumbles winnings I want that
give it to me
I wish I could just follow this way oh
[ __ ] give it back give it back give it
back but uh that's the second one that's
the second sort yeah I [ __ ] up for our
first story we're talking about dad milk
that just sounded nest and I don't think
I wanted to hear dad milk add milk it
sounds like the dads lacked hitting he's
feeding the kids yep for some reason I
feel that the dad milk is nastier than
mom knows it is cuz guys are gross yeah
you guys are all sure that's true cuz
when I think of mom melon I think of
like smoothies when I think of dad milk
I think of like aged cheese yeah there's
a product design student named Marie
Claire she's from London a magazine
that's her name Marie Claire a store I
don't know anyway so she's a product
design student and she's in the process
of making a chest feeding kit and I'd
already exist well it's not what you
think though it's different so we have
talked about like chest feeding or
whatever yeah but that's like using the
mom's milk or formula right where the
guy kind of straps on this contraption
he's feeding other milk okay this one
this involves a cocktail of hormones
without the man will start taking when
as soon as the woman finds out she's
pregnant so he can develop his own milk
ha ha he can not breastfeed the beaver
so that's like it's like steroids yeah
it is you can't go back from that though
it [ __ ] with you I'm actually down with
the concept because I wish I could share
responsibilities in chat or even y-yeah
but going against the way you're
designed is [ __ ] crazy but what if you
get some real nice titties though no
it's nothing you can have bruised up to
like a size D then we've get a [ __ ]
divorce cuz uh there's only one person
in the family that can have nice titties
okay that's right you yeah I don't
I would like if it's temporary I would
want it so I could play with my titties
but don't you feel like okay I'm trying
to be woke I feel like I'm pretty woke
but I feel like if I saw my fiancee
breastfeeding my child like I would just
be so confused I don't know what I would
you might get horny no I don't know
maybe I would or maybe I'd be grossed
out or like Jeremy being which is not
for is no necessity for it though
you know what I mean so hear me out on
this like it's like the reason why so
you could share responsibility but then
there's other ways to share
responsibility aside from that for sure
so there's another one so they're saying
that this would be more geared towards
partners where the mom is having trouble
producing raw milk but it's like how do
you know that if she has to take this
from the beginning of the pregnancy or
what if mom just takes that so it helps
her - that's a pretty good one this help
just do the dads also create like
antibodies and stuff to the way the mom
does that's the thing so that's why so
this is still in the concept stage it's
not an actual like it hasn't been
produced but they're like doctors are
saying like well you know there's no
proof that this could even work or like
that men could even make milk and if
they can make it look like they have
I've seen it dude well there's videos
online with guys that still that that
for some reason they have the the ducts
or the glands to create milk there's a
guy in high school that he was in the
cross-country team for some [ __ ]
reason came out he goes hey you want to
see something and he goes and then he
just started coming up oh I wonder if
it's nutritious that's what's gonna get
it so that's why the doctor is saying
that they don't even know that if this
would even be beneficial for the baby at
all I wonder if it's shooting blanks cuz
um I would see the benefit in it if like
let's say I can't produce milk and I'm
on my second kid now and my kid the
first one didn't get antibodies and I'm
like oh man like I wanted to get all
that good the goodness that I create and
then if he's able to I'm like all right
well that's we're doing it for her kids
I'd get like a nursing Mattie yeah
I'll get donated Miller yeah milk that's
donated and I mean I'm just saying I can
see it if it works that way and some
people might be like now we're keeping
it in the family I think if it's like
plan H maybe I don't know watch so many
other [ __ ] plans before that I feel
like it's a problem but I feel like this
solution is making this a bigger like
adding more obstacles and we're also
thinking about Mills as Mills what about
ah like transgender but I'm just
thinking about this I feel like that
titty Mel's gonna taste like cigarette
butts yeah it just tastes like cigarette
butts whiskey and chewing tobacco yeah
guys are nasty as [ __ ] yeah it girls in
general just smell better tastes better
everything yeah I think guys just embody
like bitterness or some [ __ ] there's
just [ __ ] grease coming out it's
gonna be like an alkaloid if you think
of all the animals if you think of all
the animals that we eat we eat the
female we don't eat rooster how many
chickens yes I mean unless it's fish you
know you eat the chicken you eat the cow
right yeah we don't eat balls
maybe pig is the only one I don't know
yeah maybe but guys are just nasty and
musk Li and they don't taste good they
don't like man yeah yeah this has got to
be the most like gender II [ __ ] make
a statement bull [ __ ] that I've ever
seen do y'all have a good point though
like what if it's not for like the
people you know well if it's for there
but they specifically wrote here it's
for husbands yeah
wait there why if you know K yeah and if
you are doing the whole gender like
change transitioning yeah like that
you're probably developing titties
anyway yeah you probably have better
procedures than this already that's true
I was trying to justify this product cuz
I think it's weirdest but she was board
up Mary Claire she's coming up with some
new [ __ ] oh yeah so she's saying that
she hopes to have an actual product and
like within five years that's cool I
mean there might be those families where
they're like you know what I'm a guy but
I want to experience the joys of
breastfeeding I guess and if they do
and then they get the baby [ __ ] clown
on their [ __ ] nipple and biting it
and they can feel that connection that's
true of a guy with like we don't even
have the same like pain threshold as
women we're gonna [ __ ] die that's
awesome I'm happy you just admitted that
yeah you guys [ __ ] shoot a football
out your [ __ ] come on and do that I
[ __ ] [ __ ] do something hell a big yes
I cry all of the tattoo artists always
say that to that girls can take pain way
more than guys can I feel like I can't
though you can whatever use via me yeah
every tattoo artist that ever matters
tell me girls can take pain way better
than guys do you have natural
painkillers no how you doing yeah I've
been told I'm a little bit you complain
a lot but it's not as bad as you're
complaining I don't know like I can't
get my ears V pierced I thought then
Pierce ones are you are a little bit I
can't get them re-- Pierce but I want to
wear earrings and there was even this
thing where he was like how about you
earrings if you get your ears pierced I
still can't do it
I still can't pierce me your old clothes
it takes a second though it's like yeah
it's like a rubber band and it's done
know if they're getting a shot you can't
get shot deployed by you're probably
more psyched out from thinking about it
than actual paint for sure so it's
making the pain worse merula has hella
earrings a hundred years dude that girl
oh I she could have make up her mind she
has like cartilage ones a lot of
earrings and alright next story this 87
year old man was on his way to buy a
lottery ticket when he fell and broke
his hip oh and so he was taken to the
hospital this takes place in New Jersey
by the way it's taken to the hospital
and then the nurse is there they were
just like man like you know you really
want to participate in a lottery thing
so we're gonna have you join our
Hospital pool of 141 employees and they
ended up winning it was a million
dollars that they won that they get to
split between every so they've chipped
in two dollars so everyone gets like ten
thousand or something no it comes out to
about 4500 after taxes
that's as I said so he like stumbled
onto this doll yeah he gets to pay for
his medical bill yeah so this is like a
feel-good story because a lot of people
are like that's so sweet they didn't
have to do that that I have to like put
them into the pool you didn't have a
walker with the tennis balls on it yeah
you felt broca's here I know but if you
had some thing that hold on to you
desist like maybe he was walking just
fine
and it was just any cuz for me I would
rather just not win and keep my hip is
way more taking my five years to heal so
much more money yeah yeah so this is
Earl Oh with the lottery together
I wanna hey yeah [ __ ] yeah
oh my god how long is she that is funny
because the winnings are just gonna go
to pay for his [ __ ] replacement or
whatever what'd you guys do with you won
the lottery right now oh that's easy how
much much money you know one point
things Bell yeah first thing I would do
is I would buy that ring off you and I
throw it in the [ __ ] garbage I think
the first thing I would do if I could
not do [ __ ] yeah I wake up without a
single [ __ ] worry in my mind hey I'd
pay everyone out and I'm like that's it
I'm Thomas I'm Alfie I'm going it's
going my email and do a email blast and
everyone to say [ __ ] you yeah I got my
cell phone text everyone saying [ __ ] you
and then go up but then make another
list of all my actual friends like hey
sorry I just have to send that off yeah
and go on even my [ __ ] you just [ __ ]
everybody I would hire six assistants to
take me everywhere like I don't want to
use my [ __ ] legs dude I want you to
just carry me everywhere just [ __ ]
walking around like this you know wait
what is that called rickshaw yeah Oh
perfect other sections gonna have me
carry with me by hand but I don't want
to buy a house all right expensive here
yep 300 million or 400 million b-but you
wouldn't
by a house if you have 1.6 billion
dollars what you said you won't buy a
house be up well I will we all heard
that you wouldn't want to buy a house
because it's expensive here no I said I
would want to buy a house cuz now have
money because it's expensive you can
find the crazy
I won't even buy a [ __ ] house dude I
just live in an apartment on get [ __ ] I
got so much money I don't want any of
that responsibility I would buy all of
your tenants outside super quiet oh yeah
I would just buy the whole time just buy
the [ __ ] house you stupid no no no
that's different I just I just I want to
live it in the part of it I'm trying to
downgrade in my life but upgrade at the
same time I'll buy a [ __ ] house on a
cliff that sees the ocean oh hell no
going up there cuz you have to like you
know zig zag I'm like I'll buy one at
the bottom but I'm also have a driver a
helicopter helicopter yeah oh yeah I'm
thinking to smoke our sick what would
you do that like windy road oh yeah I
would like to say that my life would it
change too drastically okay miss Venus
no no cuz I'm like no no because I'm so
like I'm anxiety driven that I'd like in
this mentality of like it's always
always gonna go away so like I'm like a
hoarder mmm this exact post but what
would you guys do to like weed out the
bullshitters oh that's easy from I
didn't read I did I did read like one
lotto winner what they did is they
called up everyone and they asked to
borrow a large son of muffin sum sum of
money and everyone that told them that
they will yeah or they you know what if
they just can't like they just can't
because they don't have that money I
think it was an amount that was
reasonable but it was big thousand
dollars or something like that
yeah I gotta fake my best I gotta fake
my death I would hire people I would I
have a coffin I want to look alike to
like lay there but oh my god y'all
like that and then in my will my fake
will it's gonna say whoever loves me the
most or deserves this money gets all the
winnings and then I'm gonna watch all my
friends and family fight to the death
and then the one that's like mature I'm
like oh my god she looks like Willy
Wonka yeah like something like that like
I'm evil it's gonna be like well you're
gonna keep the money though yeah it's
gonna be like here's like 1% see you
later
but like nice you know so much work just
for that but I know he'll be so
entertained if you have that much money
I feel like I would stick all of my high
school bullies into a room and like
throw a little bit of money in there and
then just like see what happens and this
is why rich people are [ __ ] crazy and
every person that I hate I would hire
them to be my bodyguard and then I'm
gonna go into a krip neighborhood and
wear blue red no they're gonna have to
do I'm having 400 of them well that's a
small list
we're on last story here this was kind
of a downer so there was this lady that
was in a bus in China and she missed her
stop in the month and so she started
arguing with the bus driver and the bus
driver was telling her like you know
just get off on the next stop like
there's no stops around here I can't
drop you off immediately and this
escalated to the point where yeah for
else you can't do that know in Taiwan
you can well I dropped off anywhere they
were crossing a bridge perfect over the
Yangtze River but the funny thing is she
she could get up off the next stop and
then get on the other side of the road
and it takes you [ __ ] back right but
instead this [ __ ] lost her life because
she hit the driver to the point where
the driver ended up going to the
opposite the wrong lane there was a car
there the car hit the bus and fell and
the whole bus is gone higher bus 15
people died you [ __ ] Oh mother
around it though 15 people died here oh
my god
so he's arguing she starts hitting him
with her phone he heads back but then he
ends up hitting a car Oh what the camera
survived
I'm glad the footage dude that looks
like a movie Oh oh [ __ ] I hope that
can't stick a swim everybody died yeah
everyone what about the people in the
other car oh the lady that was driving
the red car she was fine like oh thank
god
it looks like a [ __ ] movie yeah
everyone that looks like a moon you know
it's crazy so initially this was
reported as the woman in the red car was
driving on the wrong side of the road
and it was her fault why the bus had to
like swerve and oh my god and then all
this like everyone started rallying
against like ban all women drivers like
William drunk [ __ ] Asian logic close
my [ __ ] it's not women drivers do it
it's just Asian drivers no it's Chinese
Chinese specifically Chinese what
doesn't make sense either in their logic
it's like okay ban all women drivers
what do they have to take to get to from
point A to point B a bus and look at
this [ __ ] lady in the bus and causes
halt and all women from Guinea and any
vehicle ever I thought they're gonna say
ban all red cars and I'm like there it
goes again
lucky color man my fiance's Chinese so I
know a lot about this that won't so he
read up on it he said it's huge right
now so essentially about a month before
this incident happened there was another
woman who was like beating the [ __ ] out
of another bus driver in a different
City and like all the people of
passengers in the bus like thought it
kicked out of the bus but law
enforcement couldn't do anything because
in that like area there's no law unless
you literally physically hurt something
or cause like government damage you
can't get arrested so that lady a month
ago beat the person Devery went to jail
so people are saying this bus driver was
trying to get into a small collision
with that red car not run off the bridge
but just to get into a small accident so
that this woman would go to jail because
at that point then
because when you look at him like he's
like really swerving it and then some
people are saying that it's like the
like the pilot [ __ ] like when you're in
the air and you turn too many times so
you think that you're crashing even
though when you're not yeah so they're
saying like he's looking at the road and
then looking to hit her smack her in the
face and then looking back so then he
was trying to go right but then he made
a left off the brake mm-hmm so there's
like conspiracies of like did he do this
on purpose or not yeah so there's just
it's both of them it's really believable
though because people do get into
traffic like [ __ ] you know fake fraud
insurance fraud all that [ __ ] so that
that makes sense because everyone has to
have those dash cams over there because
there's all these people that's trying
to [ __ ] do fake accidents and all
that if I'm driving and I have like
people in a vehicle that I'm responsible
for I would have just stopped people how
to stop the vehicle I would a chokeslam
that [ __ ] [ __ ] slammer in the
concrete and just left I know cuz all
he's innocent people had nothing to do
with it if people if he was driving
erratically people arguing in front like
that I would get up and do something
because that's dangerous that's [ __ ] I
would have grabbed her by the [ __ ]
hair and smashed her into the [ __ ]
face yeah now I was I didn't know people
die like that
but all my [ __ ] if you can cause acid
well they're arguing in the front of the
bus like you gotta stop it man while
they're driving yes dangerous you
literally just gotta [ __ ] choke that
[ __ ] out yeah so they're saying that
the the waters about 230 feet deep and
that's like where they found the bus and
they quite died on impact if I didn't
die from drowning it was probably just a
bus flying through the air and him yeah
yeah hope so cuz I would hate to know
that anyone in that dirty ass river -
and then maybe they find
initially they just found two bodies and
then they started finding the rest so up
to like the latest information fell out
of the blush the latest information that
I have is that they found 13 people and
two people are still missing cuz it was
15 people total there they went through
PayPal just went home they went through
2300 hours of surveillance
220 dash cam video clips and then they
interviewed about a hundred and three
see vehicles like drivers and passengers
I think in Asia like it's mandatory that
you have a dashcam right I don't know I
think it was that Russia
I know Korea there's no rush I don't
know if it's mandatory but they do do it
because of the fraud that people try to
come in do you guys - counts no I should
know you shouldn't want to get one I
know but it requires for me to go get it
installed it's a lot of work just got
one because she was she got it - accent
in the parking lot because she was about
to back up so then she stopped because
she saw another car back up and they
just kept going and then they hit her
and then she couldn't prove that they
that she stopped and then they backed
into her because it was a parking space
so it could have been both of them that
backed into it yeah just a lot of people
are just really angry at that lady
obviously for causing it well I mean
drop on the drivers end to like he could
have focused on the [ __ ] road and not
being petty for sure and hit her back or
anything yeah she's still driving at a
speed that can cause that kind of an
accident and fall off the [ __ ] bridge
especially on a bridge - oh well if I
was if I died an eye shadow [ __ ] beat
the [ __ ] out of them as a ghost I was
like what do you think going with it
[Music]